now the category of sound mixing now
sound mixers have been called the
superheroes of post production and not
just by their mom on them other people
say it too
now they're two heroes to all of us in
in the movie industry the nominees for
sound mixing are David Parker Michael
semanek Ren Kleiss and Mark Weingarten
for The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
Laura Hirschberg Gary Rizzo and Ed
Novick for The Dark Knight the intact
Richard price and result opt for Slumdog
Millionaire
[Music]
Tom Myers Michael semantics and Ben
Burtt for wall-e Chris Jenkins Frank a
Montano and Peter 4:8 for wanted and the
Oscar goes to Slumdog Millionaire is
have riches right and default Oh Kathy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
accepting the Oscar is resumed the Kuti
[Music]
this is unbelievable
we can't believe this Oh ladies and
gentlemen sorry I share this stage with
two magicians you know who created the
very ordinary sounds of Bombay the
cacophony of Bombay into a soul-stirring
artful resonance called sound Slumdog
Millionaire I come from a country and a
civilization that given the universe a
word that word is preceded by silence
followed by more silence that world that
word is home so I dedicate this award to
my country Thank You Academy this is not
just a sound award which is history
being handed over to me my sincere and
deepest gratitude to my teachers Danny
Boyle Christian Coulson all Ritchie
rubbish Tabu and everybody who is
country with it's film Glenn Fremantle
and all the sound mixers I dedicate this
to you guys Thank You Academy thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes they still have me here
I believe Hugh is napping